Hey a fuckers.
What's going on?
Everybody?
Um,
comedy dates.
I got coming on September the ninth.
I am going to be at the Masonic
Auditorium in Cleveland.
I'm pretty sure Joey Diaz is doing now
with me.
He said he wanted to,
I have to confirm,
but September 9th,
I'm definitely going to be there at the
Masonic Auditorium.
No,
it doesn't mean I had to become a
Freemason,
but a masonic auditorium.
CLEVELAND,
September nine,
Joe Rogan.
Dot.
Net forward slash tour.
Uh,
and also next Friday,
the 5th of August,
I'm going to be at the Ice House in
Pasadena.
I don't have the lineup yet,
but a bunch of,
a bunch of local guys,
bunch of awesome comics from the whole
anglaise area.
Uh,
and all right,
uh,
ads,
um,
or do I got left ziprecruiter.
Ziprecruiter.
This podcast is brought to you by
Ziprecruiter if you're hiring.
And,
uh,
you need to find out how to get the best
candidates for the job.
Most of the time what people do is you
have to spend your already limited
resources and go out and try to find
somebody.
You've got to post these,
uh,
jobs to a bunch of different websites
and a post these opportunities and hope
that someone responds that meets your
criteria and find you've got to find
someone that fits the bill.
But the problem is if you are trying to
find someone to fill a position,
you're already low on resources.
Well,
ziprecruiter has an amazing solution was
ziprecruiter.com you can post your job
to a hundred plus job sites,
including social media networks like
facebook and twitter,
all with a single click.
You can find candidates in any industry,
any city nationwide,
just post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll into ziprecruiter's.
Easy to use interface,
no juggling emails or calls to your
office.
You can quickly screen candidates.
I'll say it again quickly.
Screen candidates,
rate them and hire the right person
fast.
You could find out why ziprecruiter has
been used by over 800,000 businesses
right now.
My listeners can post jobs on
ziprecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com forward slash rogen.
That's ziprecruiter.com forward slash
Rogan to try zip recruiter for free,
ziprecruiter.com forward slash rogen.
We're also brought to you by ring.com
ring.com is an amazing video doorbell
that's been proven to stop burglaries
before they happen by allowing you to
see and speak to anyone approaching your
door just using your smartphone.
Because most of the time what happens is
people ring a doorbell,
they make sure no one's home,
and then they break in.
Well with ring.
This advanced motion detection
technology allows you to protect your
entire property with ring of security
kit.
This kit includes the ring video
doorbell for the front door and a ring
stickup cam,
a wireless weatherproof hd camera that
allows you to keep an eye on other parts
of your property.
The ring doorbell and this tick up both
install minutes.
They worked together and they provide 24
seven monitoring of your entire home,
whether you're in the living room or
whether you're thousands of miles away.
It's a fucking beautiful idea,
ladies and gentlemen.
And for a limited time,
only the listeners of this podcast get
$50 off the ring of security kit,
the lowest price anywhere.
Go to ring.com forward slash Rogan.
Now that's ring.com forward slash rogen
joined the hundreds of thousands who
protect their home with ring ring.com
forward slash rogen and we're also
brought to you by ting is the last one.
Ting is the official cell phone,
cell phone,
marble mouth fuck cell phone provider
for the podcast ring,
Ting Tang ring
ting is the official cell phone provider
for the podcast.
If you go to rogan.ting.com you can find
out what teaching is all about.
With Ting is is a cell phone company
that buys time on the sprint and the
t-mobile backbone.
So,
um,
there's two different types of signals
when it comes to cell phones.
There's cdma,
which is verizon and sprint.
And then there's GSM,
which is t mobile and at and T.
And with Ting you don't have to become a
part of these big corporations companies
to use their backbone use ting.
And by using ting,
what they call Wah Wah,
you know,
they're slogo makes mobile makes sense.
It actually doesn't make sense.
You save a shit load of money.
If you go to ting,
ill tell you exactly how much you would
say save,
but I believe I'll pull it up here but I
think they said the average person,
their bill is here,
knows their average bill is $23 a month.
Um,
$440 is the average annual savings per
device for a business with 11 to 20
employees.
And again,
you're using sprint,
you're using t-mobile,
using big companies.
If you want to cancel you,
you quit anytime you want.
There's no contracts,
you only pay for what you use as another
beautiful thing.
Like if you use two minutes a month,
that's what you pay for it.
You use a hundred,
you pay for a hundred most of the time
you have plans.
Like if you're with a big company and
it's,
you get a hundred minutes a month or
whatever you get.
If you go over that,
you have big fees you pay.
If you go under that,
you don't get any money back with ting,
no early cancellation fees,
no early termination fees.
Quit whenever you want.
No ad alongs,
no bundled charges,
no fucking weirdness,
man.
Real simple,
real easy.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com and you can
save 25 bucks off of any device or
service.
That's rogan.ting.com and we've done,
this episode is with just me.
I'm alone in a hotel room.
Uh,
I was supposed to do an episode with my
pal Duncan Trussell,
but Duncan trussell caught what is being
referred to as the nerd flu.
Um,
apparently when people go to comic con
every year they get what they call the
nerd flu.
And with the nerd flu is,
is people that are like,
I guess either they don't get out much
and when they do get out,
their immune systems are severely
compromised and these fucking bugs just
run rampant through this sea of Dorks,
something like that.
Or,
um,
maybe it's just the factor of having so
many people in a room together or so
many people in groups together.
I Dunno what the fuck I'm talking about,
but Dunkin sick of shit.
That's my point.
So Dunkin couldn't make it today,
but he will be back on Monday.
So what I did was I,
um,
put up some questions are I've put up a
post on twitter and let people ask me
questions and,
uh,
I answered a few of them.
And so that's this podcast.
I hope you enjoy it.
Please welcome me.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen.
So I am in a hotel room right now in
Atlanta,
Georgia.
And,
uh,
I almost didn't make it to Atlanta.
I almost accidentally went to Chicago.
I've been traveling so much lately.
I literally forgot where I was going.
I don't think you're supposed to say
literally there.
Actually,
I actually forgot where I was going.
I went to the,
uh,
gate at American Airlines and,
you know,
when they call first class,
all the first class people like,
Ooh,
that's me.
Everybody else has to wait.
Well,
that I was one of those assholes and
I've went up to the gate and,
uh,
gave the lady my phone,
you know,
because it's a,
it's in your phone.
They scan your phone and she puts it
down.
I go,
she goes,
sir,
this is for Atlanta.
And,
uh,
I look up and the plane was going to
Chicago and I was like,
oh,
dummy.
So,
uh,
that was made,
that was one of those guys in a big rush
to get on the plane that I'm not even
supposed to be on.
Uh,
but I made it here.
I love Atlanta.
Atlanta is a bad ass place.
It's a fun town.
Uh,
I did a special here in 2012 and just
always enjoyed it here.
It's a good city.
It's an unusual city.
It's very,
uh,
I don't know.
It's got its own thing,
but a lot of cities are like that.
A lot of cities have their own thing.
Sitting here in my hotel room,
I was going to do a podcast on the plane
and uh,
I put it out on twitter.
I said,
you know,
if you have any questions,
I'll answer them.
And I was thinking about doing it on the
plane because the plane had Wifi,
but there was this lady behind me with
her kid.
Oh my God.
Some people just don't fucking pay
attention to their kid.
They just,
they,
they just don't,
they just don't do anything.
Her kid was going fucking crazy.
First of all,
he was kicking the back of my seat
constantly,
just kicking it and not like putting his
feet up and resting.
Just Som thump,
thump,
thump.
He's a cute little guy.
He's a little tiny fellow.
He's probably only maybe two or three at
the most.
And I really liked kids.
Um,
maybe I would have been irritated if I
didn't have kids.
I probably would have been.
But what was irritating was delayed.
He was ignoring him.
Um,
and uh,
she was lying there with her eyes
closed.
She was big fat lady and her kids go on.
Yeah,
Mama,
Mama.
I mean yelling.
And I finally,
I sat up and I turned around and looked
at her and she looked at me like there
was something wrong with me.
I was like,
Bitch,
talk to your fucking kid.
He's screaming at you and you're
ignoring them.
Some people just decide that because
they have to deal with the burden of
taking care of a kid and you know,
kids,
they have a short attention span.
They want your attention when they want
it.
They don't want to wait.
They don't have any patients.
They're fucking babies.
It's,
it's uh,
you know,
two to three year old baby and she just
wasn't having it.
She thought she thought she should be
able to just relax and that everybody
else,
she,
I guess she just didn't take any
consideration and all,
all the other people around her,
while her kid is fucking screaming,
she's just laying there with her hands
folded in her belly and she didn't like
this fat belly.
Her hands were laying on top of her fat
belly and it wasn't pregnant.
I don't think she had three kids there.
She might've been just really into deck.
She might had another baby on the way,
but I think she was just fat.
I'm just going to guess she was fat and
this fucking kid was screaming in her
face and she just kept her eyes closed.
God dammit.
Pay attention to your fucking kid.
Lady.
Um,
but it was pretty evident right away.
There was no way I was going to be able
to get a podcast going and just talk
into it without this kid screaming in
the background,
which I mean,
might've been funny.
I Dunno.
I'd be more likely it would have been.
So,
uh,
I didn't do it,
but I'm here in my hotel room right now
it's five 20 and I have a show tonight
at eight o'clock,
so I've got a couple hours here to kill.
Um,
so I figured I'll do it here and I was
going to have my friend Ian Mccall Lawn
if you've,
uh,
Ian been on the podcast before.
He's been on fight companions before and
he's one of the UFC is top flyway
contenders.
He was scheduled to fight tomorrow,
but his opponent,
Justin scoggins did not make weight.
It's very unfortunate because a,
justin is a very,
very talented guy and I was looking
forward to watching that fight.
It would have been a really interesting
fight.
Um,
one of the big fights on the card that I
was looking forward to,
but so ian,
um,
wound up training for six weeks and
weighing in all for nothing.
He decided to weigh in any way just to
prove a point.
Um,
he fights at fly weight,
which is 125 pounds.
It's a brutal cut.
I think he probably walks around
somewhere around 150.
If I had a guest and he's got a cut all
the way down to one 25 and he just
decided to do it anyway just to make a
point because he's a professional.
So,
um,
hopefully we'll do a podcast later with
Ian.
You know what,
while I'm doing this,
I'm doing this on my eyes.
Whoops.
Okay.
Doing this on my iphone and I realize
why I'm doing it.
That I do not have airplane mode on now
I do.
So people can't call me cause I think if
somebody calls you,
the recording just stops.
So it's ongoing now folks.
And it's sitting here.
My mic stand is a diet coke can and a,
so I'm going to read some of this shit
that uh,
people,
um,
the questions people asked on,
on the twitter.
So I'm here,
I'm doing the laughing skull and Atlanta
tonight for two shows.
It's a cool little room,
but when I say a little room,
I mean it's fucking tiny.
I think it's a,
I think it seats 80 people and I was
just here a couple months ago,
uh,
for the Tabernacle.
I was at the Tabernacle Theater,
which is a big ass place and I just
decided like I don't really have that
much new material because really I was
working on,
um,
it just tightening down all the material
that I had for my special.
And um,
once I recorded a special,
now I'm in sort of like a,
um,
I guess you would call it subject
acquisition mode where I sort of sit
around and try to figure out what I'm
gonna,
what I'm going to expand upon,
like what,
what ideas I'm going to start planting
and then try to make them grow on stage.
This is the,
this is a scary part of doing standup.
I wouldn't say like obviously it's not
scary,
but this is the,
the most uh,
troublesome or nerve wracking or,
or exciting.
It's the most exciting time of standup.
The most exciting is certainly like the
actual filming of a special that's very
exciting.
And the idea that it's done and okay,
I did that material,
the best justice I could do and now I'm
going to release it.
Um,
and then the most exciting part after
that is this,
this period that I'm at right now where
I don't have shit,
I don't have any new material.
I have a bunch of subjects.
I have a bunch of ideas that I wrote
down on my phone.
I have a bunch of subjects that I talked
about on stage a few times,
but they never really became bits.
And I will eventually piece those out
and I'll put those up on a corkboard
with index cards to take index cards and
a right the subjects down.
And I slapped him up on a cork board so
I can look at them in my office.
And A,
I've got a few of those,
but man,
this is about as fresh and embryotic a,
uh,
state as my standup is ever in.
It's,
um,
there's a period that I've been over the
last few years.
I've been doing it every two years.
Every two years seems to be like a good
number for me.
Like I guess I could probably do a new
hour every year,
but I don't think it would be,
it's at its best and some of those bits
they get better as time goes on.
And I would,
I would love to have what I think is as
close to the finished version as I can
before release it.
So,
um,
so two years seems to be the,
the time that,
and so there's this period where you
sorta slammed down the Samurai sword,
you hammer it down,
get it to the,
the best edge that you can get it to,
and then throw it all away and start
from scratch.
So that's where I'm at,
you know?
So,
uh,
these kinds of podcasts probably help
subject matter,
um,
is,
it's just up in the air.
I mean,
I don't know what the fuck I'm gonna
talk about.
So let me get,
get,
get to some of these questions.
I'm kind of rambling here.
Uh,
let's see what we got here.
how can we help governor Gary Johnson
grow on social media,
etc. That's a good question.
Governor Gary Johnson.
I should tell you guys this.
A former governor,
I can't,
are you always a God?
He's like,
you know,
they say President Carter,
like Jimmy Carter's obviously not the
president anymore,
but they still call him president
Carter.
Uh,
I don't know how that works,
but what I do know is that he will be on
the podcast next Thursday with Doug.
Stan hope.
So Gary Johnson and Doug Stam hope
together because Doug has an idea of a
great idea that we're going to announce
on the podcast.
I guess I could kind of announce it now
or talk about it now with Doug's idea
is,
is to do a live podcast during election
night and election night coverage
podcast and do a series of podcasts
actually live from the comedy store.
So the idea is we get a bunch of
different guys who have podcasts and
gals and you know,
whoever signs up for whoever we decided
to have on it.
But,
uh,
I believe bill burrs in,
I believe Mark Marin's in Doug's in,
I'm in.
And what we're gonna do is we're going
to do these podcasts live and either
we'll all on stage at the comedy store
at the same time or we will,
uh,
we'll mix it up and,
you know,
we'll have like shifts or something like
that or I think it's probably going to
be as,
as informal as possible.
So that's the deal.
I'm uncomfortable here cause I'm sitting
down in this weird way where I'm trying
to lean into this microphone.
I think when you get too close to these
things and picks up a bunch of pops.
So let me see if there's a better way
to,
I don't want to change the volume of
this.
Oh,
here's another crew.
So that's the,
that's the answer to that.
How can you help Gary Johnson?
Um,
I think a lot of word of mouth,
you know,
just talking about tweeting,
tweeting about it,
uh,
people read your tweets,
even if it's only a couple of people,
they'll tweet it out and spreads,
um,
you know,
tweet anything that you find that's
interesting.
Interviews of his,
maybe my interview that a I did with him
on the podcast.
Um,
other stuff that you can find him on
Youtube.
He's the most reasonable guy,
in my opinion,
running for president.
And people don't take him seriously
because he's a libertarian and it's
either Democrat or Republican or waste
your vote.
That's like the mindset that we have
here in this country.
I think that this election is probably
going to change a lot of that.
Um,
I think that what,
what we're looking at right now is
probably one of the worst cases of,
Oh,
I don't want to say the lesser of two
evil.
I just,
I don't like it.
I don't think you like,
I don't think anybody likes it.
I don't think that what we're,
uh,
what we're being offered right now is
the best,
the best options available.
I think it's the only options because I
think the job sucks.
I think nobody wants that job,
but Gary Johnson apparently wants it,
but it's just,
it's a fucked up job.
And I don't want to sit here and dwell
on politics and talk politics,
their buddy.
But it just to me is one of the most
depressing times ever for a picking a
president.
Um,
steven crowder from louder with crowder.
He's been on my podcast before.
He just put a video on youtube about all
the reasons why you shouldn't vote for
Hillary Clinton.
And he details all the different times
she's been caught lying and not just
lying about little shit lying about big
crazy shit.
Like the origin of her name.
She said that it was named,
she was named after someone who was like
the first guy to climb Mount Everest.
The,
but something like that.
Some someone to climb mount.
Not,
not,
not that.
I don't remember what it was.
Anyway,
uh,
it turns out the guy who she's claiming
she was named after did what she was
claiming he did when she was six.
So there's no fucking way that's true.
She lied about that.
She lied about a bunch of things.
She's,
she lied about Benghazi being by,
um,
a video.
I don't know if you guys remembered
that,
but there was a video that someone put
on youtube that it was some video about
Islam and it was really bad.
It was like a terrible,
terrible movie.
Some like ridiculously bad,
like amateur shitbag movie.
And the word was,
the word on the street for Awhile was at
that movie was the motivation behind the
attacks on Bengazi and it's total horse
shit.
And it was what the narrative was though
for a while.
And uh,
I mean Baby Hillary Clinton didn't know
any better,
but either way,
it's a,
it's an interesting video to watch if
she was,
you want to watch this video and decide
why you don't want to vote for Hillary.
But there's plenty of videos out there
that will let you know why you shouldn't
vote for Donald Trump either.
I mean,
fuck am I rambling about here?
Um,
I'm being political and we have a cup of
coffee here.
Uh,
so that's,
that's the answer.
Gary Johnson,
if you just,
you know,
tell people you enjoy is that he's a
fucking reasonable guy.
I got hung out with the guy.
I shot pool with him.
He's very reasonable.
Could he survive the barrage of the,
the trump,
the trump ads?
What do they call the trumpkins?
The guys who are really into trump?
I don't know those,
that's how that's a fucking weapon he's
got,
it's like back when opie and Anthony had
the pests,
they would turn the pests on them,
but then eventually the pest turned on
them.
It's interesting.
Um,
so that's the Gary Johnson answer.
Who's fatter Thompson or Bert Kreischer
that's a very good question to very good
question.
I don't know if you realize this,
but to my very good friends,
Tom Sigar and Bert Kreischer,
they're both hilarious guys and they
have decided to do this thing where
they're calling each other fad.
They're both,
I love them both to death,
but they both lose a couple of pounds.
They could both lose a little.
Um,
and they've just decided,
uh,
to,
have this public thing where it's like,
Hashtag bird is fat.
Hashtag Thomas Fat.
I'm going to move my phone to this new
thing.
Ooh,
that's better.
Um,
and so they sell t shirts like half
Hashtag Thomas fat and Hashtag birdies
fat tee shirts and all the proceeds for
the sales of those go directly to them.
So you're not helping any fucking
charities?
No starving.
Kids are getting fed.
They're just going to buy food and get
fatter.
And Burt's case,
he's probably going to buy boxes of
wine,
Burg drinks,
boxes of wine in an evening.
And someone's trying to explain to me
how many bottles of wine that is and we
don't really know.
I could google that.
I'm going to google that right now.
Let's find out.
If you had to guess,
how many boxes of wine would you say?
Let's take a quick,
let's see,
I guess how many or how many bottles
rather?
How many bottles of wine or in a box?
All right.
Haley.
Bottles
of wine in a box.
Here it goes.
Um,
I'm good.
Before I click on it,
I'm going to say,
I think,
I think it was nine.
I'm going to say nine.
That seems like a lot for bottles.
Okay.
Oh,
no,
no.
Okay.
Six,
six and two thirds bottles.
All right,
here it goes.
750 milliliter bottles.
How many?
750 milliliter bottles are there in a
five liter box of wine.
It's six and two thirds.
And if it's a three liter box of wine,
it's four bottles.
Hmm.
I bet he's drinking the six and two
thirds in a night.
I think he's done more than one.
I forget what he said,
but he's definitely drank at least one
box in a night on a regular basis.
So that's four bottles of wine.
I would be dead.
I don't know how he does it.
Well,
he's,
he's definitely fat.
I mean that helps it a,
and then it's also,
there's a,
there's a tolerance issue.
When you drink that much all the time
you bought,
your body just gets used to it.
There's um,
you know,
your body's like,
okay,
this asshole is going to be porn
poisoned down the hole every day,
uh,
time to get used to it.
So that's why
mythbusters mythbusters.
How many bottles of wine in a box?
I've been told a box of wine is
equivalent to five bottles.
Now I got to see if it's truth or a
myth.
We kind of,
that's not a myth.
It's a measurement is just somebody's
wacky website.
Um,
so that's what the Bert and Tom Acoust
fat thing is all about.
So if you,
if you see Hashtag Bert is fat,
that's what that's all about.
Uh,
or Hashtag Thomas Fat,
which is sort of a retaliation and they
would call him Bert Chrysler.
I don't know.
Um,
Tom's podcasts with his wife,
Christina Palicki.
They have this podcast called your mom's
house.
It's fucking hilarious.
It's really funny and it's really,
it's really unique.
It's really their own kind of thing.
I only did it once,
but it's really fun.
They have their own vibe.
They're the,
they're the pound for pound funniest
couple,
Tom and Christina.
It's close.
It's like bonding.
Mcfarland.
Rich Vos are right up there.
But um,
man,
Tom,
I think Tom and Christina might have
them buy a hair by hair.
All right,
next question.
Boy,
some of these questions are fucking
terrible.
We'll the doom podcast ever happened.
That's a good question.
Soprano pictures.
Yeah.
I probably will.
Um,
as just been crazy busy.
editing the comedy special right now and
when that's over I'll have some rest and
relaxation time and yeah,
we'll probably,
but we're going to do is it probably
won't be like a regular podcast because
it probably won't be that interesting to
listen to or watch.
We'll have it just like as like a
supplemental thing or we'll do it on
twitch.
Twitch is this thing that uh,
these young kids are doing these days.
Twitches this.
Um,
and I'm sorry if this is popping,
I might be too close to this if I'm
popping my peas twitches.
His thing that um,
young kids are doing words.
You're watching video games being played
by other people and it's really popular.
Hugely popular.
In fact,
they make money from it.
They,
they play video games and they make
money playing video games.
Like who saw that coming?
Nobody.
Right.
Nobody ever thought that it would be
interesting to watch people play video
games,
but when I used to play quake,
people used to get into these things
called demos.
Like you would watch guys like there's
this,
this kid named thresh.
He was like the big game or back in the
day,
um,
the big quake players like one of the
best in the world if not the best.
And uh,
I would watch his demos just cause he
could fuck black guys up playing that
game in a way that I could never do.
And I think if you can watch someone do
something,
like what I was competing in taekwondo
tournament's one of the things that
really helped me a lot was I would go,
like when I was coming up,
I would go and watch like big time
tournaments.
Like I went to Colorado Springs to watch
the World Cup and this was in like,
I would say like 1986 I think it was.
And I went to Colorado Springs to wash
the World Cup because I knew that the
best fighters in the world,
we're going to be there.
The best taekwondo guys,
guys like herb Perez and um,
God,
I'm trying to remember some of these
names.
Um,
there was this guy,
not seem,
no,
I don't remember his last name,
but he was this bad motherfucker from
the Ivory Coast.
Boy,
I'll remember it as soon as this podcast
is over,
I'll remember his name.
It's driving me crazy.
Um,
Patrice,
patrice remark,
that's his name.
Patrice remark was his name,
was not,
not seeing,
not seen was another guy who is also a
bad motherfucker.
There was a bunch of them.
But anyway,
these guys were like at a very high
level,
um,
much,
much better than me.
And I remember going and watching them
compete made me better.
I remember seeing that level of
competition and then all of a sudden in
my mind,
uh,
I had higher expectations of myself and
a higher,
um,
higher,
higher ceiling I guess of potential.
Like I looked at all these guys and how
good they were and I realized what was
possible.
So it,
it sort of ramped up in my mind what I
needed to do to be at my best.
And immediately afterwards I went on to
win one of the biggest tournaments over
one,
which was um,
well one of the biggest in
Massachusetts,
the bay state games,
which was right after I got back it just
from watching,
I got better.
Guaranteed point is we would watch these
things,
um,
these uh,
demos in quake.
So what you could do is there was a,
you had hit the till Dickey until the
key is that key that's right below the
escape button on your laptop or your uh,
your keyboard rather.
And it would pull this dropdown menu
like a,
like a control panel,
not even a dropdown menu.
It was just like,
it was like code,
like dos and you'd have to type in
certain things.
I forget what the,
how you would do it,
but you had to learn like what little
symbols to use and stuff.
Like it was almost like kind of coding,
but you could,
you could type in demo and you could run
a demo and then later on,
I think they put it in the menu,
the actual menu of the game.
But in the old days,
like especially the quake one days used
to have to uh,
used to have to know what to write in
the code and then you can record demo
and he would record a demo.
And this way you'd be watching the game
play out from the person's eyes.
Like you would watch their screen,
like what they're seeing when they're
playing the game and it made you better.
It definitely did.
And I think it's exciting to watch too.
It's exciting to see if someone could
pull something off.
Like I'd watch this a thresh guy or um,
there was another guy named a mortal,
he was a bad motherfucker and uh,
he was uh,
another guy who was like one of the best
in the world.
You'd watch him play and you just go
cheese us.
Cause he would,
he would hit guys like there'd be an in
mid air,
like jumping and he would shoot them in
the face of the rocket.
Just he was so good.
He would rail guys,
they had a rail gun.
Is this this a super high powered thing
that shoots this?
I guess like,
I don't know what a rail is,
a ball or something like that,
but it has this cool like tracer behind
it,
like this laser tracer like show and
it's almost like instantaneous.
Um,
the,
the speed in it,
it's faster than a rocket and you'd be
able to,
you'd have to time it just absolutely
perfectly.
And these guys would be able to do
things with those rail guns that were
just so impressive to someone who's suck
like me.
You did watch it.
You watch it through their eyes and like
fuck.
And it just made you realize how bad you
socked and how good they are and how
much you had to,
how much more you had to work at it.
It was like,
one of the weird things about those
games is,
um,
how deep the rabbit hole goes.
Like the guys who are like really good,
they were so much better than,
than someone like me who was kind okay.
Like I was okay as long as I was playing
somebody who sucked or somebody who was
like,
at my level,
we just really didn't know what they're
doing.
And I was fucking playing a lot.
I was playing like eight hours a day at
one point in time,
sometimes even more completely obsessed.
I would,
it would,
it would fuck up all sorts of aspects of
my life.
I wouldn't get anything done that would
be constantly like just engrossed in
improving my performance in this fucking
crazy game.
And playing it online too was so
exciting because you'd be playing
against a bunch of people and these
people would be,
you know,
in real time essentially.
There was a little bit of lag in between
when you would shoot and when it would
show up on the screen,
dependent upon how fast your connection
was.
But if you had a pretty decent
connection,
like cable modem or something like that
and you know,
the person was near you,
like fairly close in the same city or
something like that,
or at least in the same state,
you'd get like really commensurate pings
and you'd have these awesome matches
where you'd be basically playing in real
time against each other.
It's just so exciting.
And these levels that you would play on
if you've never played it.
3D shooter like unreal or quake or doom
or um,
there's,
you know,
there's a bunch of them now,
but these games that you would play,
the graphics would be so intense,
there'd be all these wild maps that you
would play on.
It was just really exciting and so much
more exciting than any other game or any
other thing that I've ever done before.
Um,
you know,
outside of fighting,
uh,
in a competitive way,
which just completely engrossing.
Uh,
so I,
I really had a problem with it for a
long time.
If you listen to this podcast for any
length of episodes,
I'm sure it's come up more than once.
I know I talk about the same things over
and over again sometimes.
And that's unfortunate,
but I always feel like somebody's,
somebody's listening doesn't know that
story.
And if I don't tell that story,
it's not going to make sense.
The people that are the hardcore people
that have heard this podcast,
you know,
listen to a hundred plus episodes.
You probably have heard that story,
but you know,
the,
the real issue is how many people that
are new that are tuning in for the first
time haven't,
I don't want to leave it out just
because I'm worried that someone's
already heard it.
So I always try to put that caveat in
it.
For those of you who have heard this
before,
I'm sorry.
So my,
um,
my video game career as far as a,
I wouldn't call it a career obsession.
My,
my period of obsession lasted a few
years and I eventually had to quit cold
Turkey.
I had to walk away cause it was just
really interfering with my life.
And,
uh,
here's another story that I've told
before,
but I'll tell it again just because
people haven't heard it.
There was a guy who was a manager of the
comedy store.
It was a really nice guy.
His name was rob and rob was a in the
back of the comedy store once and he
said he was addicted to everquest
and everquest was,
uh,
like world of warcraft was one of the
first,
one of those,
um,
role playing games.
Those multiperson weird world games
where you,
you know,
I'm a sorcerer and you have either cloak
and go get a bag of gold and was wacky
fucking games.
But he was super addicted to it.
And one of the things that he said was,
he said,
I'm so good at making money in the game
world,
but so bad at making money in the real
world.
And the way he said it was like this
revelation,
like what the fuck is wrong with me?
He was really devastated and he was
sitting there,
he's Pale,
looked like he hadn't seen his son and
weeks he looked like he hadn't sleeping
right.
His eyes were all fucked up from staring
at a computer screen every day.
And that was the moment I think where I
realize like,
oh yeah,
like these fucking things will sap you
have your life.
Like it might be fun while it's
happening,
but it's,
when it's over,
it's not fun.
Like the memories,
they're,
they're weird memories.
Like,
if you play a game,
like say if you,
uh,
play a baseball game and you knock a
home run out of the park and everybody
cheers and he run the bases and you high
five your teammates,
you have a good time.
That's a real memory.
But if you play a guy in a video game
and you play for eight hours and you
beat him in some,
some crazy match when it's over,
he don't feel like anything really
happened.
I wonder if that's the case.
If someone's playing in a major
tournament,
maybe it was just me because I have the,
uh,
I had the,
the thought in my head that I was
wasting my time like that,
um,
I should be doing other things.
I have things that I need to be doing
and I'm fucking off and playing this
video game.
And so I had like a negative attachment
to the idea of playing a game.
And maybe if I was like one of those
dudes are like one of those starcraft
games.
I don't know if you're familiar at all
with video games,
but if you,
uh,
if you are familiar,
you know that they have these crazy star
craft tournament's in Korea and um,
I guess they have been America too and
that they,
maybe Europe as well.
Maybe I'm just talking out of my ass,
but in Korea I know they're huge and
they fill up arenas.
I'm talking like,
like a fucking Coliseum,
like 25,000 people and they have these
giant screens and people watch these
guys play video games in real time and
they cheer and they know like the moves.
So when someone's doing something good,
they get crazy.
And when someone's making a mistake
they're like,
oh no,
it's weird.
It's weird to watch.
And I believe there's real money in it.
Like I know there's,
um,
guys that do play in video games and
tournaments and then professional
video game leagues that can actually
make real money.
And then they make that money on that
twitch thing as well.
Twitch,
uh,
I don't know.
It's twitch.com I guess they somehow or
another,
I don't,
it's been explained to me,
but I forgot.
There's,
um,
I guess people,
I don't know if you get paid per how
many people are watching you or people
donate or,
I dunno,
they make money.
They make money off of twitch.
So there's that.
So maybe those people that are playing
these,
these big time,
starcraft tournament's maybe to them it
feels the same way as it would feel if
you were a major league chess player and
you won a tournament.
I swear.
Because some games are highly respected
and some games nobody gives a fuck about
like games.
They carry their own sort of,
I dunno,
not really prejudice,
but games have their own little thing
that they're attached to them,
right?
Like chess.
Chess is a thinking person's game.
And if you tell someone you played
chess,
they're like,
Ooh,
you must be smart.
Right?
It tells me to play poker.
They go,
oh,
you degenerate gambler.
Fuck.
Like there's,
there's games that people don't
appreciate.
Like you tell someone,
yeah,
I'm uh,
I played for professional pool.
They go,
oh,
that's a thing.
You know,
it's not like something like someone
saying they're a professional chess
master.
I mean a grandmaster of chess.
It becomes,
um,
that,
that's like very respectable.
Grand Masters.
Very close to grand wizard though.
That's one of the hilarious things about
the KKK.
They've wizards,
the grand wizard.
Like what?
He's a grand wizard of the KKK.
He's a,
he's a wizard.
You fucking child.
You're a wizard.
Uh,
have a fuck that I get.
Their point is there's no point.
I have no point.
Point is,
um,
video games.
Uh,
they scared the shit out of me because
they'd cost me a few years of my life.
Not really.
I mean,
I had a good time.
I had fun,
learned,
learned that I have a problem with games
along the way,
but I already knew that because of pool.
And a,
I knew that because of martial arts too,
because martial arts,
it's very similar in a lot of ways to
games.
Most recent podcast,
Brian Callan,
we,
uh,
we talked about that with,
um,
we're talking about Josh Waitzkin who is
a famous chess prodigy who,
uh,
I feel like he was the inspiration
behind the movie,
searching for Bobby Fischer,
looking for Bobby Fischer or searching
for Bobby Fischer,
the movie with the Little Kid who was a
chess master.
I'm pretty sure Josh waitzkin was a,
um,
a big part of the motivation or the
inspiration for that movie.
And he went on to become a really
fascinated by Jujitsu,
was a student of Marcello Garcia.
I'm pretty sure he's a black belt now.
He's a brown belt back when I was
communicating with them on online,
were sending emails back and forth
because my friend Nathan was training
with him and,
uh,
he connected the two of us together.
And you know,
Josh is a fascinating guy and he was
also responsible for Marcello Garcia
putting a lot of content online,
I believe,
I hope I'm not wrong about this,
but Marcello Mig and action was a really
interesting website where Marcello was
constantly rolling with people rolling
with new people in a school.
And he was,
uh,
you know,
like people would come in and train with
them.
Like Eddie went down,
Eddie Bravo went down there and he
trained with them and they film it.
They put the role,
the sparring session online.
But they're all very friendly sparring
sessions,
but,
you know,
competitive.
And if you don't know,
Marcello Garcia,
he is a fascinating character himself.
He's a brilliant,
brilliant Jujitsu player who's a really
nice guy.
And you look at him and he's like kind
of baby faced and smiley,
but he's just one of the best in the
world.
And,
um,
he doesn't compete anymore.
He's getting older and you know,
he stepped down.
But I,
I had,
uh,
the opportunity to watch him compete in
2003 and Brazil in Sao Paulo,
Brazil.
Um,
that was back when,
uh,
Eddie Bravo,
choked out.
Hoya gracie are tapped out horribly.
Gracie with a triangle choke.
He was the first American never top of
Gracie.
And in that main,
uh,
tournament,
that's this huge Abu Dhabi submission
tournament.
The star of the show was Marcella
Garcia.
He was without a doubt the star of the
show.
He,
uh,
fought this guy,
he had a match with the Sky Victor
Shaolin who barrow,
who was a very respected Jujitsu guy and
he choked him unconscious and it was
just a wild scramble.
He caught his back and Shaolin tried to
roll out of it and marcel just sunk it
in deeper and deeper.
And before Shalon could even tap,
he was out cold and,
uh,
Marcella was just running through the
competition.
I remember we were all watching him
going,
Holy Shit.
Who is this guy just came out of nowhere
and was just so dominant and so dynamic.
And he had some really specific moves
that he liked to hit.
Um,
and particularly the way he would take
people's backs.
He was so good at chokes and he also had
a really scientific approach,
um,
where he wouldn't want,
if you guys can hear that the fan just
kicked off,
do you care?
No one cares,
right?
Bitch off.
Off.
Yeah.
It goes.
Um,
but he,
he had,
uh,
an interesting approach where he had a
few techniques that he would do,
but he would do them extremely well.
Like he didn't have this gigantic
arsenal that he would attack with.
He would attack with gay teens and you
attack with rear naked chokes.
And there was a lot of things that he
wouldn't do.
He wasn't a big guy.
It wasn't like a big muscular guy,
which is one of the more interesting
things about him when you look at him.
It wasn't a scary guy.
He wasn't like,
there's certain Jujitsu guys,
you look at them and you go Jesus,
like who some are Pahar s is one of the
best examples of that cause he's just
built like a freak.
Like he's built like the comic book
version of Wolverine.
He's a short guy with giant muscles,
just thick fucking neck,
just terrifying guy rips people's legs
apart too and doesn't necessarily let go
when they tap.
He's kind of known for that,
which makes them even scarier.
He's injured a lot of guys,
but he looks like a scary guy.
When you look at Marcello Garcia,
he's like a really smiley guy.
And,
um,
because of the fact that it wasn't a
very physically nothing,
he wasn't physically strong,
but it wasn't a freak athlete.
It wasn't just explosive,
dominant,
just really muscular guy.
He developed just razor sharp technique
and leverage and that's how he won his
matches with,
that's how I ones matches,
which made it even more impressive
really.
And his,
his main techniques were chokes.
So most of the time it's putting guys to
sleep or,
or forcing them to tap.
But there was a lot of techniques that
were really common well-respected
techniques that he just never used.
And he would openly talk about them.
Like the Camorra,
uh,
which is a famous technique is actually
called the double wrist lock in catch
wrestling,
catch wrestling.
When people think about pro wrestling,
we think about pro wrestling.
You think about like Hulk Hogan and the
Rock and the Seattle tricks and these
pre scripted events.
But wrestling used to be at one point in
time,
it used to be an actual match.
Like there was actual professional
wrestling and there was a,
uh,
a style of wrestling called catch or
catch as catch can think.
That's how they would say and catch
wrestling.
There's like these guys like Karl gotch
and farmer Burns and a lot of guys who
wound up teaching,
uh,
some modern day MMA fighters and
grappling competitors like Josh Barnett.
Josh Barnett is probably the most famous
and the most successful catch wrestling
enthusiast and practitioner like Josh
Barnett is tapped out some really famous
Brazilian Jujitsu competitors like,
uh,
here on Gracie or a dean lister.
Dean lister being an incredibly
impressive,
because Dean hadn't tapped to anybody
and I've got,
I want to say at least 10 years when
Josh finished him in,
uh,
this competition called metamorris.
But,
um,
that's what wrestling used to be.
And they had a bunch of submissions.
Like a lot of the submissions that we
think of as Jujitsu submissions also
existed in catch wrestling.
And I guess when people are,
you know,
grappling,
I mean,
the people been grappling through at the
beginning of time.
I mean,
when people first started fighting,
that's probably how they fought each
other.
They probably grabbed each other and got
close enough to bite or hang onto each
other.
And then slowly people started
realizing,
hey,
you know,
when I do this,
it seems to keep the guy away from me.
Or when I do this I can hold onto them.
Or I used to hold them like this,
but now I realize when I hold him like
this,
it works even better.
And,
uh,
when I do this,
it really hurts.
And when I do this,
it doesn't hurt.
And so they,
you know,
I mean,
back in the days of the spartans and the
Romans,
if you look at some of the statues,
like I was in Italy recently and we
were,
we went to Rome and we,
uh,
looked at some of the,
the artwork of the Vatican in
particular.
There's just a lot of statues of guys
wrestling,
a lot of,
lot of looks like,
like grappling holds and grappling
position.
So it's been around forever.
But what Brazilian Jujitsu really was,
is these guys who are not very big,
Elio and Carlos Gracie of there,
they weren't the biggest guys in the
world.
There were small and they weren't
physically strong and they figured out
how to use technique and leverage to
overcome physical strength.
And one of the matches that Eylea got in
early in his career,
he would have these crazy matches with
people.
He had a match with this guy named
Kimora and Kamora caught him in,
um,
what catch wrestling would call a double
wrist lock where you clamp down one hand
on the wrist and then you throw an over
hook around the arm and clamp your other
hand down on your wrist.
So you have one hand on his wrist,
one hand on your wrist and it creates
this awesome fulcrum point and you can
manipulate someone's arm.
But Marcello Garcia always felt like
that position required a lot of physical
strength and he wasn't a very strong
guy,
so he just abandoned that.
He just decided it wasn't an option and
it was just going to concentrate
primarily on things that were sort of
just had ultimate technique to them.
And chokes pretty much have ultimate
technique.
And one of the reasons why I chose an
ultimate technique is if someone lands
it perfectly,
they you go unconscious.
Whereas an Armbar like guys have gotten
their arm broken before and come back
and fought and won and had their heart
are awfully hyperextended and come back
and won.
Like a perfect example in Jujitsu is
Hodrick gracie versus joc arrays is a
very famous match between two guys that
are competing in mma now.
But back when they were fighting and
Jujitsu,
they were amongst the best in the world.
And Hydro Gracie caught jock Ra in an
arm bar and snapped his arm and jockey
would not tap,
he would not tap.
And he fought out of it.
And eventually,
um,
he was ahead on points when he got up,
uh,
when he got out of the arm bar,
but his arm was just destroyed.
So if I remember correctly,
I think he might've even tucked his arm
inside his belt and just kept going
until the time limit ran out.
And then a raised his one good arm and
got all excited and you know,
had one because he gutted it out and
would not tap when this guy snapped his
fucking arm.
And this is by the way,
professional Jujitsu.
This isn't even mma.
This is not like a,
you know,
a Rhonda Rousey match or a conor
mcgregor fight where they're making
millions and millions of dollars.
I don't know how much money this guy was
getting paid for for this Jujitsu match
in his sponsors and how much it was
actually worth to him.
But as far as his pride,
it was worth it to him to actually get
his arm broken instead of tapping,
which is fucking crazy.
Uh,
so boy,
that's a long and circuitous.
I've lost my own train of thought.
My train of thought was that there's
certain techniques that you could really
hurt a guy,
but they don't have to quit.
And Hydro Gracie landed the perfect arm
bar on Joc array,
broke his arm and jock rates still won
the fight on points at least.
I mean,
if they had been fighting old school
gracie way,
your probably would have eventually got
him because Jacari really couldn't
defend himself correctly anymore.
And he would,
he would eventually,
since he's only got one arm to defend
himself,
heidrick probably would have wound up
choking them or catching him in
something else.
Uh,
but you know,
it's entirely possible he wouldn't,
and it's totally possible that Shakuri
even with a broken arm could have gotten
him.
But the point being when you choke
someone to sleep instead of break their
arm,
they can't do anything.
They're done.
You,
you put them to sleep.
And that was Marcello Garcia,
his philosophy.
He realized that he could just put
someone to sleep and then they could be
no debate as to whether or not he was
going to win and no debate as to whether
or not the,
the move was actually efficient or
effective.
It was obviously affected.
The guy was asleep.
And,
uh,
that's what we saw in Brazil when he
fought a Shaolin and just put him to
sleep.
I mean,
seconds too.
It's a crazy,
crazy video that you could watch on
youtube.
Um,
so Josh Waitzkin,
who was a,
um,
a student of Marcello's put all of 'em
Marcello's moves and sort of just sort
of like a,
as something that people can learn from
and grow from and put it all online.
So Games doing podcast.
So Josh who is a,
obviously because of he's a chess
prodigy,
is fascinated by games and chess being
one of the most intellectually inspiring
games got really into Jujitsu as well.
So I just know because of the way I got
into martial arts and the way I got into
video games and pool,
it's just,
there's something about those weird
challenges that can really,
they can,
uh,
really excite the mind.
The only problem is I don't necessarily
know if they have the same kind of real
world benefits as getting really good at
a sport or getting really good at an
actual physical activity where you move
around and do things.
So
I dunno.
Uh,
but we will eventually do a doom podcast
and I will,
uh,
I will prepare myself where I make sure
that there's no fucking way I get
completely and totally addicted anymore.
Cause I've been there,
I've been there.
It's not the move.
I can't,
I don't have time for that anymore.
Uh,
other questions here who will do
international paper view instead of you?
Uh,
if you don't know what that question is
about.
I uh,
decided recently I was getting,
at one point in time it was going to not
work for the UFC anymore.
I was going to just do these fight
companion podcasts that I do with Eddie
Bravo and Brendan Schaub and Brian
counts sometimes and,
and other people sometimes too,
when those guys were out of town.
I did one recently with Joey Diaz was
one of the best ones ever.
But what did it,
what the fight companions are as we just
sit around and we'd watch the fights and
we talk some shit and I don't,
I'm not working that way.
Um,
I just work a little bit too much,
um,
between standup comedy,
writing,
standup comedy,
doing podcasts,
researching the guests,
researching subjects.
I'm researching potential guests.
Uh,
and then life,
you know,
all the other things that I have to do
was exercise,
Yoga,
forget about family time,
all that other stuff is,
you know,
that also there's a lot of time that is
already accounted for.
And then there was a ufc and I had to
figure out what things I wasn't,
what,
what things I could cut back on.
I wasn't going to cut back on family
life.
Um,
I wasn't going to,
I don't,
I don't want to cut back on my
recreational activities because they
keep me sane for,
for,
for me.
I need a bunch of stuff that I'm
interested in.
I can't just work.
Uh,
even though work is awesome,
I love doing stand up,
uh,
love.
I even love doing the UFC.
I love it.
I mean it's,
it's a very exciting job and it's an
honor to be able to do,
but,
but it's,
it's work and it requires energy and it
requires focus.
And I feel like at the end of the day,
you only have so much energy and so much
focus and you could be in a situation
where you almost are two fortunate and
you have,
you have too many things that you enjoy.
And that's where I kind of found myself.
So,
um,
so that's
what I decided.
I sided decided what I'm going to do is
I am going to only do North American
paper view.
That's it.
No more fox shows,
no more long international flights
because first of all,
those things fucking wreck your body.
They're wreck me.
I would do them.
And then for days like I just got back
from Italy.
It took me like a week,
like at least four or five days before I
felt it felt normal again.
It just,
your buys all fucked up,
you're jet lagged,
you're confused,
you're exhausted.
You just feel,
you feel like you're at 60% all the
time.
You're always trying to push through.
And uh,
it's a drag enthusiasm and having a
vitality like physical vitality and
feeling good and feeling healthy is a
big factor in life for me.
Um,
that's,
that's a huge thing.
I like feeling good.
I like being healthy when I know
something is going to make me feel
physically bad and make me feel
unhealthy.
I try to avoid as much as possible.
Uh,
you know,
there's sometimes I give in like,
uh,
maybe I'll have a couple of drinks with
some friends and we get a little crazy
and the next day I'm like,
Oh,
you dummy.
I've done that before obviously.
But even the,
like a hangover,
I feel better in a day.
Those fucking jet lags like,
uh,
a flight from,
oops,
a flight from Sydney just knocked over
the phone,
a flight from Sydney,
Australia.
That shit takes me a long time to get
better from a,
I don't want to become complaining here.
My point being,
I try to avoid things that make me feel
shitty physically.
And unfortunately a lot of flying makes
you feel shitty and especially flying
along hours.
So who's going to do the international
paper views?
I think with the way they're doing it
now is Dan Hardee was a former fighter
and,
uh,
he's been a guest on his podcast.
He's a fucking awesome guy.
Super Smart Dude.
Super tuned in,
really interesting and intelligent guy.
And um,
Dan actually trained with Dan for years.
Back in the day when Dan used to train
at 10th Planet Jiu Jitsu,
whenever he was in town,
he was getting ready for a fight.
He would come to a Eddie bravos gym and
train.
I trained with them multiple times.
Super Nice Guy.
So Dan Hardee,
we'll probably do a lot of them.
And then of course,
Brian Stann who is fantastic,
who was also been on his podcast,
he'll do a lot of them.
Um,
and then there's also,
Kenny Florian is also great.
He'll do,
I don't,
I don't know how they worked that out.
Like who does what,
but those are the ones that we're going
to do it.
So,
uh,
that would be the answer to that.
You fucks.
I don't know.
I mean,
I really don't know.
Um,
I dunno what's gonna happen with this
new ownership thing?
Either there's a bunch of new people
that uh,
took over the UFC now that u of c is
still going to be run by Dana White,
which is one of the reasons why I
decided to stay
because a,
you know,
Dana and I are or close,
we've been good friends for a long time
and I,
one of the things that I was really
nervous about was the idea that Dana was
going to leave and some suits are going
to take over and then I was going to
have to have meetings with people.
They're going to tell me what I could or
couldn't say or give me advice on how to
do it or any of that stupid shit.
I was like,
fuck this.
That was like,
it was answering the question for me,
like what am I going to cut back in my
life?
As soon as I heard that they were
thinking about selling,
I was like,
well they're,
that answered it for me.
But as time went on and I really thought
more and more about it,
I,
I really thought that I would miss it
and I don't want to.
And also,
um,
I mean,
I don't mean to sound Corny,
but all the love that I got from people
online,
it influenced my be my,
my thinking too made me think that I
probably should think about sticking it
out.
So,
uh,
that's the answer to that.
What do I think about the Fermi paradox?
That's an interesting question.
If you don't know what the Fermi paradox
is,
the actual definition is you to here,
the actual definition is a,
it's about aliens.
The question is where are okay,
here it is.
Where is everybody?
The idea is if there is an is named
after,
I'll go to the wikipedia.
The fermi paradox is named after Enrico
Fermi,
uh,
as the apparent contradiction between
the lack of evidence and the high
probability estimates,
those given by the drake equation for
the existence of extraterrestrial
civilizations.
And the drake equation is it's,
uh,
an equation that's here.
I'll go to the wikipedia that it,
it's used to arrive at an estimate of
the number of active communicative
extraterrestrial civilizations in the
Milky Way Galaxy.
And the Fermi paradox is if you look at
all of the stars in our galaxy alone,
billions of stars and billions of
galaxies,
hundreds of billions of stars,
hundreds of billions of galaxies,
many of them which are many,
many,
many years older than our galaxy,
many years older than our planet.
The question is why haven't these aliens
contacted us?
Where is everybody?
So that's the question.
The fermi paradox.
I've thought about this a lot,
so I'm actually happy about this
question.
I have a feeling that our ideas about
what a society or what civilization does
as it advances are based entirely on our
idea that we are dependent upon the
monkey body that were dependent upon the
physical flesh and the idea of being
somewhere in a measurable way that
that's the only way you can experience
something.
Um,
I think that that,
I think that's,
that's an error on our part.
I don't think that we are going to be
attached to the physical body forever.
Does it sounds like hippie nonsense,
silly woo bullshit.
But this is my thought behind it.
I think that first of all we are moving
closer and closer every day to being
integrated with technology and by
integrated with technology.
I think initially it's going to happen
where there's going to be some sort of a
chip that we have in our body,
whether it's uh,
something that we use that it helps us,
enhances our vision or enhances our
mental function or our ability to
communicate with each other or our
ability to access information.
It's entirely possible that it might
start out as some sort of a helmet that
we put on that lets us,
you know,
like maybe like a ball cap with
electrodes on it and you put this thing
on and it stimulates areas of your brain
that allow you to see these images.
And maybe perhaps like some sort of a
screen like minority report,
like it'll be in front of you.
Will,
you'll be able to access data,
will,
you'll be able to ask it questions.
I mean I have is hey siri function.
We have this,
Hey Siri,
function on our,
um,
our phones that people get pissed off
when I say it.
When I say those words on the podcast,
because if you have an android phone,
you don't know this,
but if you have an iphone,
you have that option on.
If someone says those words,
Hey Siri,
your phone goes buddy.
Like you're asking it a question.
So you say,
Hey Siri,
where's the fellow?
Get a blow job around here,
or whatever.
Ask it some questions and it'll actually
answer you.
You,
you could say,
hey,
Siri called Dunkin.
It'll call Dunkin.
Uh,
Hey Siri,
navigate to the Hollywood bowl.
It'll give you the directions to get to
the Hollywood bowl in real time.
It's amazing.
And it's science fiction.
It's something that just a few years ago
was completely outside of our
imagination.
We really didn't think that they were
going to have something that sat on the
table next to you.
Some small little sliver of glass and
metal and whatever the fuck it's made of
electrodes.
No,
it's in their silicone.
That you could talk to that thing and
say,
Hey Siri.
And it would,
uh,
you,
you could say,
Hey Siri,
what is the Fermi paradox?
And it would google it for you.
This is all something that's going on
right now and this is just one step.
It's one step in what is really as long
as human being stay alive as long we
don't get nuked as long as we don't murk
ourselves,
as long as we don't get fucked up by a
super volcano or an asteroid or some
polar shift or some natural disaster.
As long as that doesn't happen and we
just not,
we not obviously not me,
but people smarter than me who do this
kind of shit,
they're going to continue to innovate
and as they continue to innovate,
we're going to get technology that is
more and more powerful and I think more
and more integrated in our,
in our our lives and in our physical
bodies.
I think it's going to reach,
there's going to be a bottleneck where
holding a device in your hand,
it just doesn't have the same effect or
do the same amount of things as they
could do if they actually put it in your
head and I think people are going to
fucking volunteer for it.
I think they're going to volunteer for
it.
Like they volunteer for braces,
like they get eyeglasses at the
optometrist,
like they get fake tits people got,
they're going to get these things put in
their bodies and it's going to be really
common and maybe won't even have to be
in your brain.
Maybe that'll be the the hold back
people like I don't want to my brain,
and they'll go,
well,
we don't have to do that.
We put on your wrist.
It'll communicate with your brain
through the nervous system or through
electrical impulses through your tissue
itself.
And maybe that along with some sort of a
hat that you put on that allows you to
interface with the Internet.
That's going to be us step.
But somewhere along the line,
if you listen to guys like Ray Kurzweil
who believe ray believes that you're
going to eventually be able to download
your consciousness into a computer,
which of course gets really fucking
weird because what are you then?
Are you still there?
Here's the question.
If you download your consciousness into
a computer,
are you still existing in the physical
sense?
So if you exist in the physical sense
and your consciousness is downloaded
into a computer to do the,
to get to talk to each other,
or are you like,
do you end your life in the physical
sense and then begin one in a digital
sense and as it even a life.
But if it exists and some sort of a
matrix like state,
if they could figure out a way,
you know,
there's a lot of people today that just,
they just,
they're not happy with the life that
they've been handed with the,
the,
the roll of the dice.
Maybe they have physical deformities,
maybe they have poor health.
There's a lot of,
uh,
people that just got a shitty hand when
it comes to life.
Like a life is not even in the cards of
the deals.
I don't have to tell you this,
you all know this,
right?
And if someone came along like a,
what was that guy's name and the Matrix,
the guy who a wound up selling,
everybody who just said he wanted it to
be famous or rich or something like
that.
He's eating a steak in the Matrix and
decides to give in that that kind of
existence.
If someone comes along and says,
look,
you don't have to live this life in the
physical sense anymore,
instead of being dependent upon this
monkey body and the tooth Fang and claw
of natural selection and evolution and
this just the struggle,
the struggle of being a fucking human
being.
Instead of that you can exist in this
perfect state where you are constantly
in love and just filled with joy and
having a wonderful life filled with only
positive experiences.
And you can enjoy this with,
with no negative repercussions.
You could just,
you,
you can become a part of the matrix,
a part of the thing,
whatever they're going to call it.
And from there you will be the architect
of your existence.
You will be able to decide this idea,
that law.
Well,
the bad days,
they make you feel good about the good
days,
you know,
there's no sunshine without rain.
You know,
you got to have good and evil.
Well that's,
that's here,
that's in this state,
in this physical state.
Yeah.
You have to have good and you have to
have eagle as we know it right now in
this life.
We do appreciate our loved ones.
When something terrible happens,
when there's a tragedy happens.
Um,
we,
we do,
uh,
appreciate the people that are alive.
When someone we care about dies.
Those are all,
those are all true.
But is that the only way that we can
appreciate each other?
Is that the only way we can enjoy life?
Some people would say yes,
but I don't think they'd really know.
I think that's just,
we're basing that on what we have
experienced and what we would currently,
the data we're pulling from being a
human being,
living on earth.
If someone can engineer,
and this is not something that might
happen in a year or in a hundred years,
but we're,
we might be talking about something that
happens at a thousand years or 2000
years,
who knows?
But around the same time where we think
that,
uh,
technologically based civilization would
develop the capability of star travel,
of being able to travel not just into,
uh,
another solar system,
but perhaps he'd do another galaxy.
But maybe hundreds of galaxies away,
who knows?
But that kind of incredible ability to
control your environment.
We might not ever get there and we might
not ever get there because we realize
that being there physically is not
nearly as important as the experience.
Like um,
you know I've often said this about
psychedelics that people say,
Oh,
you know,
you have a psychedelic drug experience.
Yeah.
You,
Oh,
you're imagining things are happening,
you're hallucinating.
Well,
sort of,
yes,
but no.
Like it might not actually be happening.
Like if you have this experience,
we take a psychedelic drug and you are
transported to the center of the
universe and you are communicating with
love,
with love in the form of beautifully lit
neon geometric patterns that are
constantly changing and morphing and
they're filling you up with a wisdom
and,
and joy and appreciation.
When people say,
well,
that's a hallucination.
You're taking a drug and you're having a
hallucination maybe.
But either way the experience is still
the same.
Like the experience of meeting God
because you took mushrooms and and
having this incredible meeting with the,
the divine force of the universe.
If,
if that happens in real life or if that
happens in a psychedelic drug trip,
the feeling and the experience are still
the same.
It might not be a real physical thing
and the sense of you might not be able
to take it and put it in a pillowcase
and throw it on a scale and weigh it,
but you can't.
Who's to say you could ever do that
anyway,
like it's the exact same experience of
meeting God.
It might be just as good as my point.
So this idea that,
well I don't want to live in the matrix,
man.
I want to live in the real world.
Are you sure?
What's the benefit of the real world?
I mean it's the only reason why we think
that the real world contains some sort
of benefit for us is because that's the
only model that we have to go on that
this is the pattern that we've been
following our whole lives.
That this idea that you know you live
and then you die and then you do your
best along the way.
Sometimes you got to push through the
pain and sometimes you got to fucking
get up in the morning where you don't
want to get up and you gotta.
You gotta work hard and when you work
hard it pays off and you get a good life
and you know your,
your discipline equals your freedom and
ugh.
There's a lot of thoughts that we have
about living life that are applicable to
this physical knock on wood life.
It's real life that you and I are
experiencing right now.
Everybody listening to this podcast,
he had a pug your phone and you had to
listen to it on a computer.
You got to touch some things and
something had to happen for you to free
to experience something in a,
in a,
in a real sense.
But that's just because this is what
we're used to.
We're,
we're,
we're definitely not used to.
And if she would talk about human
beings,
if you went back 200 years ago or
definitely not used to the Internet,
we're definitely not used to movies.
200 years ago we didn't even have
fucking cars.
If you wanted a picture of something,
you had to draw it.
We're used to all these things now we're
used to photograph.
The idea of not being able to take
photos on vacation is alien.
The idea of having to get in a boat and
travel across the country.
Like I was talking about how I just got
back from Italy,
if I lived in the 18 hundreds I would
have had to been on a boat for months.
I would have had to made it from
California all the way to New York and
then I had,
would have had to been in a fucking boat
and gone across the ocean the same way
my grandparents did when they were
little kids.
My grandparents came over here from
Italy when they were like,
um,
I think my grandfather was like seven
years old.
I think he said I would've had to have
done all that stuff.
It's not going to happen.
Right.
So the idea of no photos is alien.
The idea of no movies,
no,
no cameras,
no TV shows,
no radio.
There's no radio back then.
What the fuck?
You couldn't tune into a radio show in
1800 it didn't have them.
They didn't exist.
All these things that are now a normal
everyday part of our lives.
We're alien just a few hundred years
ago,
which in terms of human civilization and
certainly in terms of the life of human
beings,
the existence of human beings,
it's not even a blink of an eye.
This is all new and we couldn't imagine
life without it.
I think if time keeps going or if rather
a civilization keeps going over time,
if we don't do something incredibly
stupid or get fucked up in some sort of
a natural catastrophe,
we're going to come up with an ability
to manipulate our environment,
our world,
our perceptions,
our mind to create an artificial world
and artificial universe.
That's impossible for our little fucking
chimpanzee brains to,
to imagine.
I don't think we have the capacity to
do,
to,
to connect all the dots.
I think with each new invention it opens
up a new complete realm of possibility.
Like you couldn't say to someone in
1,801 day you're going to have google.
Cause they'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Well one day you're gonna be able to
talk to your phone.
What the fuck is a phone?
But one day you're going to be able to
talk to your electronic device.
What's electronics?
What do you,
what does the fuck are you saying?
What are you a wizard that you would be
saying something to them that didn't
make any sense at all.
And that I think is how we have to look
at the possibility for two or 300 years
from now.
There's going to be new things that get
invented along the way.
And you know,
in the old West who's electricity that
metals,
new ways of connecting things and then
teletype and Morse code and all these
different things got invented before
they invented computers.
The Internet,
the world where we're dealing with right
now,
when,
when you look at two,
300 years from now,
I think it's entirely possible that
these ideas that we have about what the
future is going to be like.
There was,
there's big chunks missing.
There's chunks missing from a thought
process and it's because these paradigm
shifting revelations,
inventions and innovations,
they haven't occurred yet.
And when those things do occur,
I think it's going to forever change
what the future will be.
And as these things occur,
whether it's the ability to download
consciousness or whether it's the
ability to record thoughts in,
in your own mind,
record memories,
dreams,
that's a real possibility.
What their thinking is.
There's going to be a time where you
were going to have a hard drive,
like a virtual hard drive or a physical
hard drive,
rather like someone's going to put an SD
card slot in your head,
not an SD card slot,
something probably much smaller.
It might even be as small as like Ray
Kurzweil has said as a cell,
like a blood cell,
like one red blood cell in your body
that's a machine or a computer or a
camera or some sort of recording device.
This thing may be able to record your
thoughts,
record how it feels to be you.
Like say if you,
uh,
you know,
fill in the blank.
If you're A,
I dunno who Ashton Kutcher,
let's pretend you're asked in coacher.
If Ashton Kutcher decides to record his
thoughts and his life and his day and to
take it and uploaded to the web and you
could feel what it feels like to be him,
you know,
or maybe someone who you would always
love to find out how they think,
you know,
like maybe Chris Rock,
like a great comedian.
Like how does Chris Rock look at the
world?
Where's he coming up with material?
Has This guy think?
How,
what,
how does he feel about himself?
You know,
like a,
a guy like Louis C K who say I'm very
self deprecating guy.
How's he feel about himself?
You know,
maybe guy like Jon Jones,
so great fighter or Demetrius Mighty
Mouse Johnson.
How does he feel about himself?
How does he think,
what does,
what does it feel like to be him?
What does it feel like to be mighty
mouse for a day?
What does it feel like to go through a
workout?
You could actually feel it.
You get experience it.
You could beat him for a short period of
time.
I think that is inevitable.
I really do.
I think that has as inevitable as
recording,
uh,
a picture of your kid blowing out their
birthday cake and you watching a video
on your iphone when you're doing that,
when you're videotaping someone's
wedding,
when you're videotaping a sporting
event,
when you're holding your camera up at
the UFC and you're watching the fights,
you're capturing time.
You,
you will,
you are capturing an image of something.
We're so used to it.
We don't,
we don't even understand how fucking
insane it is.
It is so insane that you could take
something that's so small.
It's not even as thick as a deck of
cards.
You take it out of your pocket and it
could film hours of shit hours.
You can capture hours of images and then
you show it to me and you could have
been on the other side of the world.
You could be in New Zealand and you
could be filming some insane mountain
view that was in the movie,
the Hobbit,
and it could be you and your friends and
your backpack in there and you're
laughing and joking and you make a video
and then you can send it to me through
the fucking air and it could reach my
phone on the other side of the planet in
seconds.
This is nuts.
It's nuts.
It is completely fucking bananas,
but we're really used to it and it
stands to reason to me that this ability
is only going to accelerate.
Their only going to get better.
It's only going to get more,
more in depth.
It's only going to get,
the experience is not just going to be
visual right now it's visual and it's
two dimensional is going to be virtual.
It's going to turn into a virtual
experience.
Then it's going to be something that
involves much more than just the simple
senses of sound and sight.
You're going to have,
it's going to,
there's going to be feeling,
there's going to be neurological
responses.
There's going to be memory,
there's going to be,
then it's going to be emotional.
You're gonna be able to feel emotions.
I think we're going to be able to record
thoughts and ideas.
And the same way we're able to encode
and record visual images like
photographs or,
or audio like this podcast.
Like,
you know,
I'm sitting here right now.
What time is it?
Six 30 for Friday,
July 29th in Atlanta.
I'm recording this.
You might be listening to this a hundred
years from now in the future.
And you might be saying,
whoa.
Like I was listening to this Alan Watts,
uh,
recording the other day that was on
universal basic income,
which is a,
a constant,
uh,
subject right now.
It's been going on around the idea of a
is you actually just gave people money
so that they could live.
So I didn't have to worry about making a
living.
It would open them up to a lot of other
possibilities and at this idea that
putting people on welfare or the Dole,
it just makes them lazy,
might not necessarily be true.
And that it actually might be better if
we didn't look at it that way.
If we just looked at it the way of you,
once your basic needs are covered,
then you're free to express yourself in
a much more natural way without
desperation.
And that desperation doesn't always mean
you're going to make the best decisions.
And it really would cost us less if we
gave people money.
Okay.
Anyway,
point being this is an Alan Watts,
a discussion where Alan Watts was making
this speech about this from the 1960s so
it was more than 50 years old.
Um,
I think somewhere around 50 point being,
it's,
it's entirely possible that this
recording that I'm making right now,
someday somebody might listen to 50
years from now,
a hundred years from now,
200 years from now,
and they'll laugh the laugh at how wrong
I got it.
Or maybe they'll laugh at how I called
it and we will be living in some sort of
a strange world where reality is not
something that you measure.
You can't like take a ruler to it or you
know,
and measure the temperature of it or put
it on a scale.
It might be something that exists in
some sort of a quasi reality setting,
uh,
where it's,
it's real,
you're experiencing it,
but it doesn't exist in a physical form
that's entirely possible that that's our
future.
It's entirely possible that we through
technology,
figure out a way to create not just an
alternative dimension,
but infinite alternative dimensions,
infinite alternative existences.
So this idea that we're just going to
get to a certain point where we realize
that a,
we could build a spaceship the size of
the empire state building and fucking
shoot off to Alpha Centauri and set up
shop there and,
uh,
you know,
find some snails and turn them into
people.
I don't think so.
I don't think we're going to be
traveling.
I really,
I don't think that's the future.
I think,
uh,
I think we may for the next foreseeable
future,
for the foreseeable future,
we might be sending robots to Mars like
we're doing now and might send them off
to Pluto on to these other planets.
And we might get invaluable data about
the,
the nature of our solar system.
And you know,
there's this planet that they think is
outside of Pluto's orbit it past the
Kuyper belt.
Now they're calling planted acts and
people have talked about this forever.
There's some Chai and asked planted out
there.
That's,
I think it's more than four times larger
than earth and they're pretty sure it
exists,
like 90 something percent.
Sure.
Yeah.
That's all awesome and fascinating and
amazing and beautiful.
But I don't know,
I have a feeling that our future doesn't
exist in a physical sense,
the way we think it does.
I think we're married to this idea
because it's all we've ever known,
but I don't necessarily think it's all
we're capable of.
I think it's entirely possible that one
day we might create a whole new world.
And this also might be possible with the
advent of artificial intelligence.
Artificial intelligence is another
fucking rabbit hole because if you want
to,
you want to get your mind blown.
Listened to.
Not,
I don't think it was the last one.
I think Sam Harris and I have talked
about it twice.
Um,
we talked about it on a think the last
podcast and maybe even more in depth the
podcast before it might be both of them.
I'd have to go back.
Remember,
I've done more than 800 fucking podcast
now.
So even though my memory is pretty
decent,
I really lose track of which one was
what and what was happening when,
but,
uh,
the point being,
the conversation that I had with him
about artificial intelligence was a mind
blower,
a real mind blower where it's in my,
in my eyes.
It's one of those things,
just like we're talking about
technological innovation.
I think everyone would say everyone.
I mean just it conservative
people that are dreamers.
If we start talking about the potential
for the future,
uh,
are,
is there going to be innovation?
Yes.
Everyone would say yes.
Everyone.
If people don't blow themselves up,
if we don't get hit by an asteroid,
if yellow stone doesn't explode and wipe
out everyone in North America,
will we continue to make better
electronics where we continue to
innovate,
where we will,
we continue to make new inventions?
Everybody would say yes.
Everybody.
Well,
if that's the case,
artificial intelligence is almost
inevitable.
If it's a hundred years from now,
if it's 200 years from now,
whatever it is,
one day,
eventually they're going to figure out a
way to make something that can think for
itself.
He Tesla has fucking cars that drive
themselves.
Now you can press auto drive or whatever
the button is.
He depressed and these fucking things
will drive.
They hit the brakes,
they make turns.
They follow the navigation system.
They have sensors that detect cars.
They break at traffic.
I mean,
it's fucking nuts and it's just crept up
on us.
Nobody saw this coming 10 years ago.
Nobody thought in 10 years,
nobody thought in 2006 10 years from
now,
we're going to have drivable driverless
cars,
cars that you take your hand off the
wheel.
There's a hilarious photo of a guy.
They snapped pictures of him on the
highway,
I think it was outside of San Francisco
where he was asleep,
asleep at the wheel going to work and
his car was driving down the highway.
This is,
this is all new,
right,
and what is it going to be like 10 years
from now?
I don't think we know.
I think we could guess.
I think we could have beautiful ideas,
but I think when every new invention
gets created and every new door that
gets opened up by new technologies,
it,
it creates the potential for a gang of
other new exponentially increasing new
technologies.
So with artificial intelligence,
I think it's entirely possible that we
can literally create something that
creates universes,
something that creates universes that
don't exist in a physical sense.
Like you go to the Moon,
you pick up moon rocks,
it come back to earth,
but rather something that exists in
another dimension that we find portals
or gateways or that we find frequencies.
I've always thought that it's,
it's possible that planets themselves or
that a rather reality itself is like a
station on the dial.
And I've read that scientists believe
that there are at least 11 dimensions.
I don't know how they understand this.
I don't know how they,
they,
that's when they get to those,
you know those yellow legal notepads
where those guys scribble shit down on
it.
Your little,
what the fuck is that?
But you have to be a theoretical
physicist to in order to understand what
the fuck they're writing.
I think those guys have come up with
some equation that they all agree upon
where they believe that it is entirely
possible that there are 11 dimensions at
least.
And this is today in 2016 right?
If you ask scientists in 1955 they
probably look at you,
look,
you have fucking three heads.
That's a blink of an eye.
1955 compared to 2016 it is a blink of
an eye.
It seems like 60 plus years for us.
But it ain't shit in terms of the world
in terms of human history and in terms
of the,
you know,
the,
the evolution of this bizarre talking
monkey.
It's a,
it's nothing.
And in that time things have changed in
spectacular ways.
I think it's entirely possible that
through especially the invention and
innovation of artificial intelligence
and its ability to innovate,
it's ability to improve upon ideas that
human beings have created.
Cause that was one of the most mind
blowing parts about the Sam Harris'
podcast was he said that within weeks
they will be able to do 10,000 plus
years of what would take us as far as
innovation.
So the world will change so fast once
artificial intelligence is,
is when once it goes alive,
when skynet goes live,
the world's going to change so much that
it's almost impossible for us to
understand.
It's impossible for us to guess I'm
standing up here now cause I'm Kinda
freaking myself out
and
my throat is getting a little scratchy.
That's what I think about the Fermi
paradox.
I think.
I think that we're going to outgrow this
idea of being somewhere in a physical
sense.
And I think that if there are aliens,
they're going to contact us through our
own minds.
They're going to contact us through
dreams.
They,
they,
I mean aliens might exist in the form of
imagination.
Imagination itself might be like a kind
of energy,
like a kind,
almost like a life form.
If you look around at the world,
obviously you imagination is something
that you know,
it comes out of the brain and people
create things and it's just,
you know the idea that it's a light
farms ridiculous.
I get it.
Yes,
you're right.
But the imagination is responsible for
every single physical thing that human
beings have ever created.
This building that I'm in right now came
about because of the imagination.
The phone that I'm talking on came about
because the imagination without the
thought of these ideas,
without someone saying,
hmm,
what would happen if we took this mud
and turned it into a square and then
dried it out?
Can we make a brick?
Ooh,
and then if I stack a brick on top of a
break,
dude,
I'm making a wall.
And that all came out of the mind.
It came out of an idea.
How amazing would it be if we found out
that those ideas themselves were alive,
that that is the way these lifeforms
express themselves much.
What much like the way disease expresses
itself inside your body.
Like when you catch a cold,
right,
you,
you have a life form that's growing and
feeding off of you and your body's out
of balance.
Your immune system is battling this
virus,
this dizzy.
You could look at it on a microscope.
Ooh,
look,
it's the staff virus or it's the flu.
Oh,
it's malaria.
Ooh,
he's got the malaria virus.
Well,
what is that thing?
that thing is a life form.
It's some sort of an existing living
thing that's trying to multiply,
multiply,
and grow.
And ultimately it would like to keep,
it would like to kill your body.
It would like to take your body over and
it would love to spread itself to a
bunch of other people and,
uh,
take out a bunch of folks.
And that's what happens every year with
the flu or every year with malaria.
And if you want a harrowing tale of what
it's like to that malaria,
listen to my friend Justin Wren,
who's been on the podcast many times,
uh,
who was just on the last episode,
who goes to the Congo regularly to uh,
build wells for the pygmy.
It's just an amazing guide,
just beautiful person who is doing this
incredible thing and helping these
people.
But some motherfuckers caught malaria
three times now.
It's scary shit.
It's malaria is some sort of a weird
life form,
right?
What if ideas where lifeforms,
they're just life forms that exist in a
nonphysical way and you can make
yourself more accessible.
You can catch these ideas better.
You catch these life forms,
you can catch these things that will
ultimately lead to the transformation of
the very world around you.
They've developed air conditioning.
These ideas have made heat.
They figured out how to harness fire.
They figured out how to take rubber
tires and put them around metal wheels,
attach it to a frame and allow you to
fall asleep and side of as it takes you
to work.
That's all because of imagination.
Knows that that imagination is something
that you can't measure.
It's not a physical thing.
You can't,
you can't show it.
You know,
you don't take,
I'll go a litmus test.
You can't go to the store and hey,
I tested positive for imagination.
No,
it's,
it's just there and you access it and
you,
you sit around your daydream and you lay
on your back in the grass and you come
up with an idea.
What the fuck is that?
We don't know.
We totally take it for granted.
But if you look around this fucking
spectacular world that you see in front
of you when you step outside of your
house,
this bizarre world.
But if you lived in a,
in a natural world,
if you lived in a jungle or if you lived
in a,
in a mountain setting and you had never
seen human civilization,
you were confronted with it for the
first time,
you would freak the fuck out.
You will be like,
what kind of bizarre thing is creating
these enormous structures with a glass
and stone and on a scale that is,
it is impossible to comprehend a human
being creating a skyscraper one person.
No,
no,
no.
They had to work together.
How many people?
Hundreds.
Okay.
How'd they do it?
They have metal.
They use machines.
What machines?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They have combustion engines with that.
Well,
they're explosions controlled explosions
inside of a metal structure that that
powers these gears and these gears can
lift up things thousands of pounds and
carry them through the air and then
they,
they put these glass walls on top of
these buildings.
Like what the fuck?
This is all because of the imagination
and this,
this,
this idea that the imagination is just
some sort of like,
oh,
he's imagining things old,
silly.
He's a dreamer,
has been kind of putting our heads since
we were young,
because we're,
we're taught to be pragmatic or we
talked to talk,
to be disciplined and taught to,
to,
you know,
to go out there and get things done and
pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
And all these,
like a hardcore sort of a,
I dunno what the word I'm looking for,
organic ways of looking at productivity
in life,
but ultimately this imagination is going
to lead us to create something that can
change the very nature of what life is.
So if that made any sense at all to
anybody but me,
I'd be fucking shocked.
But that's my answer.
God Damn,
that was a long ass fucking answer.
Um,
is almost seven o'clock here and I got
to leave soon.
So maybe I'll answer one more
thoughts on the Putin,
Russia,
trump implications around the democratic
party.
Wiki leaks,
email reveals.
I think that they were saying that
people were saying that trump was going
to get in trouble because he told the
Russia to hack Hillary Clinton's emails
or hack the democratic,
um,
party wikileak emails.
That's ridiculous.
That is really ridiculous.
I think that is one of the dumbest
things.
This idea that trump should somehow or
another be accountable and held
accountable for espionage.
How about the fact that that the
Democrats were plotting against one of
their own?
How about the fact that we're working
towards getting Hillary Clinton to be
the the nominee for the party.
They're working towards that like
they're supposed to be impartial.
He's a Democrat too,
and they were actively trying to make
her
be the,
the representative for the Party and
then when the woman who has to step down
because the emails,
she has to step down because it's
revealed that they were actively
plotting to get Bernie sanders in his,
or excuse me,
Hillary Clinton over Bernie Sanders.
She,
after she steps down,
immediately gets hired by Hillary
Clinton like immediately.
It's,
it's so transparent.
It's hilarious.
I think what I was saying earlier that
one of the good things about a guy like
Gary Johnson is we're realizing how
stupid this fucking two party system is.
We're being hosed.
Whether you're a hillary supporter or
whether you're a trump supporter,
you have to admit that they're not
ideal.
Neither one of those people is ideal.
You see all those people that are at the
Democratic convention and they're all
smiling and laughing and they don't
really believe she's ideal.
They believe this is all we have right
now.
Hillary Clinton was giving a speech and
her fucking husband bill fell asleep.
He fell asleep.
I mean,
apparently he's not in good health right
now.
It's not doing so hot.
But he's sitting there in the audience
and if he,
if he's in such bad shape that he can't
stay awake,
he should be in bed somewhere.
He,
he fell asleep in the audience.
That's how fucking boring and stupid
these things are.
And it's a hose job and it's a hose job
that I think is just going to be here
for a little while longer.
It's going to be like powdered wigs.
It's,
it's,
it's a nonsense way to run a nation of
300 million informed people.
There's too many of us now.
There's too many of us and people know
too much.
It's not 18 hundreds where you needed
this sort of representative government
because you couldn't get to those people
and they couldn't get their into their
opinion to you.
That's,
it's not the case anymore.
We live in a different world.
Um,
that's it.
I'm going to end,
I'm gonna end this fucking thing.
Um,
I'm going to try to get Ian Mccall on
and either I'll attach it to this
podcast or put it on a second one
depending on how much Ian and I talk,
but this one has gone for an hour and 34
minutes,
which is I was like,
what the fuck am I going to talk about?
Meanwhile,
I couldn't shut the fuck up.
And it's weird when I'm doing these
things because you're trying to not be
conscious of the fact that you're doing
why sayings started.
Just trying to like let the thoughts
flow.
But in the meantime it's like you have
to resist the urge to think about the
fact that you're talking and that you're
talking into a phone and that you're
trying not to fuck it up and you're
trying to be as honest and transparent
about your thoughts as possible while
still make an entertaining.
Don't say too many ums.
Don't ramble too much.
It's weird.
I've done these before in the past,
but I haven't done one like this a long
time.
It just shows you how talented bill burr
is.
Cause that fucking guy does one of these
every Monday and every Thursday.
Bill Burr,
if you haven't heard his podcast,
it's awesome.
It's the bill burr Monday morning
podcast,
but he also does a Thursday version of
it,
which I think he calls the Thursday
afternoon and Monday morning podcast.
But,
and honestly,
bill is,
um,
he's a good friend of mine and a
brilliant comedian and he's also a guy
who's singular in his focus.
And a,
I really admire him as a comic and it's
one of the things I was thinking about
when I was thinking that maybe I would
stop doing commentary.
I'm like,
this fucking guy just does stand up.
I mean,
that's what he does.
He just does a stand up and look at the
results.
They're amazing.
He's always got new shit.
He's always killing it.
I love watching his act.
He's Oh,
consistently funny,
but he's very singular in its focus.
And,
um,
anyway,
I'm rambling.
Uh,
Bill Burr,
Monday morning podcast.
Check it out.
It's awesome.
If you haven't heard of bill before as a
comic,
he's not just one of the best alive
today.
He's one of the best average.
He's one of my all time favorite standup
comedians.
So with that,
let's end this fucking thing.
So,
uh,
thanks for tuning in.
Um,
I'm,
I may do this again or I might be
completely fucking burnt out or I might
freak myself out about how God damn I
sound when I start rambling about
artificial intelligence and the,
the birth of alternative dimensions and
universes out of the mind of monkeys.
But until then.
All right.
That's it.
Goodbye.
Thank you.
Appreciate the fuck out of people and,
uh,
talk to you soon.
Big Kiss.
Thank you everybody for tuning into the
podcast and um,
thanks to caveman coffee,
even though I didn't drink it because
I'm hearing my hotel room and I just had
their coffee,
which is not as good.
Go to caveman coffee,
ceo.com and find out what's up.
Single source,
single family,
single origin deliciousness,
caveman coffee.
See o.com thanks to tain go to
[inaudible] Dot [inaudible] Dot com save
25 bucks off of any cell phone or
service.
Thanks also to zip recruiter dot,
dot dot,
dot.dot.
Go to ziprecruiter.com forward slash
rogen to post jobs on Ziprecruiter for
free.
That's ziprecruiter.com forward slash
rogen.
Thanks also to ring.com.
Go to ring.com forward slash rogen and
you can get 50 bucks off the ring of
security kit.
That's ring.com forward slash.
Rogen.
I right folks,
that's it.
Podcast is over.
Um,
oh yeah,
on it go to Onnit,
O n N.
I t use the Codeword Rogan save 10% off
any and all supplements.
I'm taking my on it total gut gut health
right now.
Um,
that's the end.
The podcast folks.
Hope you enjoyed it.
Uh,
I don't know if I'll ever do one of
those again,
but I did one because,
um,
I said I was gonna so there I did it and
I'll be back on Monday and next week
should be really fucking fun and
exciting.
We're going to have a presidential
candidate,
Gary Johnson,
along with Doug.
Stan hope.
Uh,
it was supposed to be on Thursday the
fourth,
but it may now be moved to Friday.
We'll find out soon.
Neil Brennan cocreative,
the Chappelle show he'll be on as well.
That'd be on Wednesday.
And Wayne Fetterman,
hilarious.
Standup comedian,
and very,
very smart guy.
He'll be there on Tuesday.
Good Times.
You fucks.
And then of course,
I'll be at the ice house Friday night
and maybe I can talk,
stand up and do a set with me too.
All right,
that's it folks.
Thanks.
Appreciate the fuck Outta here.
Bye Bye.